bonjour à tous alors aujourd'hui je vais
vous emmener voir un monde quasi inconnu
je vais vous emmener voir ce qui est
invisible à l'oeil nu et nous allons
voir comment on peut utiliser ce monde
invisible au service de notre
agriculture
bien avant cela je vais vous parler de
ce qui nous lie tous ici nous tous entre
nous c'est notre futur et au delà notre
futur quels sont les défis qui vont être
à réaliser au cours de ce siècle
le plus important d'entre eux va être
celui du défi de la transition
alimentaire et de notre système agricole
et oui en 2050
imaginez-vous nous serons 9,6 milliards
d'humains sur terre
ça fait du monde c'est la première fois
que sur un temps si court
on a autant d'enjeux sur l'augmentation
des rendements agricoles
il va donc falloir être capable de
produire plus et c'est pas seulement
produire plus c'est le contexte qui est
autour et vous allez voir l'état c'est
complexe et avec des facteurs multiples
qui font de ce défi un véritable casse
tête
on va pas pouvoir augmenter les surfaces
agricoles
donc il va falloir produire plus avec le
même nombre voire même moins de surfaces
agricoles
ça nous donne quoi imaginer en 1960 un
terrain un champ cultivé d'un hectare
pouvait nourrir deux personnes on était
alors 1,3 milliard d'humains sur terre
2005 ce même terrain devait nourrir
quatre personnes il y avait alors
première d'êtres humains sur terre
l'aurez compris toujours ce même terrain
sur 2050 devra nourrir non pas deux non
pas quatre mais six personnes un petit
peu augmenté là donc il va falloir
augmenter cette production en prenant en
compte un autre défi
une prévision qui n'est plus une
prévision une réalité le changement
climatique global qui touche dès
aujourd'hui certaines régions du monde
et un pacte l'agriculture avec une
hétérogénéité des rendements d'une année
sur l'autre qui vous l'imaginez bien est
un peu compliquée pour les filières
agricoles
couplé à ça de façon directe ou non on a
une pénurie des ressources naturelles et
en particulier l'eau qui est pourtant un
élément clé dans de nombreux itinéraires
de culture qu'on a cette problématique
là falloir donc développer des nouveaux
itinéraires de culture qui prenne en
compte ces considérations là puis on va
rajouter encore un petit paramètres un
autre défi celui de la transition
environnementale et écologique puisque
nous avons des objectifs de réduction
des impacts environnementaux et des
objectifs aussi qu'ils répondent à une
demande de plus en plus forte de vous
tous ici moi comprise des consommateurs
qui veulent manger mieux qu'ils veulent
des produits de plus en plus naturelle
et avec le moins d'impacts
environnementaux pour ne citer qu'un
exemple encore en france on a eu par
exemple un plan le plan ecophyto qui
vise est sous forme de pallier la
réduction des intrants chimiques 25%
tout d'abord et puis 50% ambitieux
projet beau projet on a donc augmenté
l'utilisation d'intrants chimiques entre
2015 et 2016
autrement dit un véritable échec de ce
plan un échec des instances
gouvernementales sur cette question là
alors que vous l'aurez compris les feux
sont plutôt au vert c'est plutôt une
demande il est consommateur soit un
moteur en ce sens qu est la cause de cet
échec
c'est tout simplement des alternatives
aujourd'hui inefficace des alternatives
qui ne répondent pas aux problématiques
concrètes des agriculteurs et des
itinéraires de culture pour faire des
alternatives fonctionnel il faut prendre
en compte une réserve réserve de vie
encore sous-estimé qui est la vie
microbienne présente dans les sols dans
un gramme de forêt on a plus d'êtres
vivants que d'êtres humains sur terre
alors que dans un gramme d'un champ
cultivé honte
10 puissance trois micro organismes que
s'est il passé des méthodes utilisées
jusqu alors on détruit cette vie
présente dans les sols
aujourd'hui il y a un enjeu un défi
majeur pour l'humanité de résoudre ce
challenge de rénover cette biodiversité
il faut donc mettre en place des
alternatives biologique qui prennent en
compte et qui utilise cette biodiversité
naturelle au service des plantes
on pourra ainsi augmenter la qualité des
plantes et augmenter leur production
tout en ayant réduit nos impacts
environnementaux
comment faire ça tout simplement si je
puis dire en s'inspirant de ce qui
existe en ayant en allant porter son
regard sur ce qu'on ne voit pas d
alternative
je vous en présente une et j'insiste sur
le une vous verrez pourquoi on peut
utiliser et c'est ce que je développe
des interactions naturelle entre les
plantes et des micro-organismes puisque
le sol n'est pas juste un lieu de
support vous l'aurez compris mais un
lieu de vie qui agit sur les cultures
ces champignons mycorhiziens sont
capables d'interagir avec les plantes au
niveau de leurs racines et de multiplier
accrochez vous bien
mille fois la surface des changes entre
la plante et le sol
cette plante immobile est alors capable
d'aller puiser des éléments nutritifs
beaucoup plus loin que ce qu'ils étaient
capables les racines seule dalle est
accaparé non seulement ça mais ces
champignons une capacité d'assimiler des
éléments nutritifs que la plante seul ne
peut assimiler on résout donc un double
challenge on est capable grâce à ces
mycorhizes ces champignons d'augmenter
l'acquisition de nutriments par les
plantes et donc d'avoir des plantes
mieux nourris qui se développe mieux
mais il n'ya pas que ça si vous regardez
ce réseau ce maillage qui se crée autour
des racines
on a une barrière physique vis-à-vis de
quoi bein de micro-organismes qui
contrairement à ce que l'on pense sont
finalement assez rares mais sont des
micro organismes pathogènes
là on s'affranchit donc non
seulement des engrais mais également
d'une utilisation de certains pesticides
qu'on déverse dans les sols et qui se
retrouvent dans les nappes phréatiques
et polluent nos sols est nouveau c'est
une véritable innovation qui repose sur
l'augmentation de cette biodiversité
naturelle et la gestion de cette
biodiversité naturelle et ce sont ces
systèmes là et non pas les l'idée de
remplacer une molécule chimique par une
molécule biologique qui va nous aider à
aller sur l'agriculture de demain c'est
bien plus complexe que ça c'est un
changement global des systèmes de
production et ce changement il ne peut
pas se faire tout seul dans un coin ni
dans un laboratoire tout seul sans avoir
vu un champ de sa vie c'est impossible
ces changements là ils doivent être pris
par un consortium de tous les acteurs
des filières agricoles
agriculteurs industriels instituts de
recherche instituts techniques start-up
consommateurs
tous nous devons co concevoir ensemble
ces alternatives pour qu'elle soit
demain efficace dans des conditions de
vie réelle pourquoi le plan ecophyto at
il échoué parce que les alternatives but
logique actuelle sont à 80% des cas
inefficace en conditions de vie réelle
c'est aujourd'hui inacceptables non
seulement ça mais il faut proposer des
alternatives qui soit acceptée
acceptable par les premiers utilisateurs
les agriculteurs qui doivent non pas
avoir de nouvelles contraintes mais une
solution qui s'intègre parfaitement dans
leur itinéraire et qui leur permettent
d'avoir des rendements suffisants et que
ce soit économiquement aussi acceptable
pour eux c'est une des clés des
solutions j'ai insisté tout à l'heure
sur le fait de vous présenter une des
solutions parce qu'il n'ya pas une
solution à la transition agricole ça
serait bien trop simple il y a des
solutions
il faut trouver des solutions et non pas
une solution générique
il faut des solutions qui s'adaptent à
toutes les problématiques qui s'adapte
au cas par cas aux itinéraires
différents de culture et aux complexités
de chaque type de production de sol et
de plantes
eh oui
du travail mais c'est que comme ça en
travaillant cas par cas qu'on arrivera à
proposer une transition globale et
efficace et cette transition
je voulais dit elle passe pas un acteur
essentiel
l'acteur le plus essentiel de tout mon
discours il a toujours été là il est là
juste sous nos pieds c'est le sol c'est
ce sol qui doit aujourd'hui rentré dans
une gestion durable
nous l'avons malmené il ya eu certes des
méthodes agricoles qui ont malmené ce
sol on l'a vu entraîné une perte de vies
dans ce sol mais c'est loin d'être le la
seule la seule cause les activités
humaines d'une manière générale quand
même bien entaché son sol il y a les
activités humaines liés à l'urbanisation
et l'érosion qui font qu'aujourd'hui
cette gestion des sols n'est pas durable
et entraîne des problématiques grave
pour notre humanité prendre soin de ce
sol dès aujourd'hui c'est préserver un
élément essentiel à la survie de notre
humanité
et c'est grâce à ça en se réappropriant
ce sol et en réapprovisionnant cette vie
dans ce sol qu'on pourra demain être en
capacité de nourrir 9,6 milliards
d'humains dans un contexte de changement
climatique et en ayant réduit nos
impacts environnementaux et je suis sûr
qu'après tout cela vous ne regarderez
plus jamais de la même façon ni vos
plantes ni ce qui se passe sous vos
pieds merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]